الكعكة على البصق العصارة
إنه أصيل للغاية
[موسيقى]
اسمي جوزيف مفقود وانا
رئيس الإخوان الكيك
arreau بروش قصة الكعكة
البروش القليل الذي نعرفه عنه
هم جنود نابليون قبل
حوالي 200 شخص أعادوها منها
تقاعدهم الذي يحترم نفسه من روسيا
تم إنشاء الأخوة هناك أراك قريبا
20 عاما قد انقلب الجميع يعرفه الجميع
اصنع العجين
كل شخص لديه عجينة خاصة بهم
أصوات تصل إلى 109 3 كغ زبدة 3 كغ
سكر 3 كيلو طحين 2 لتر رم
وكوب كبير من الريكارد
هذه الكعكة يستغرق عمليا 4 1
ما يقرب من خمس ساعات لأنه يستغرق
ساعة لتسخين القالب أثناء ذلك
الوقت الذي يستعد فيه الأشخاص الآخرون لـ
قدم الغراب بعد ساعة نحن
لنبدأ في تمرير طبقات العجين
طبقات متتالية ونمر
عجينة لمدة أربع ساعات
عجينة متبقية من القدر
أنا لا أتعب من قلب
ستار سبت كيك نعم لا لا
ليس أكثر من ذلك
[موسيقى]
نصنع حوالي خمسين كعكة
كل عام كان هذا التقليد مستمرا
200 عام
لأن كعكة البصاق
تصبح الكعكة أمرًا لا مفر منه
جميع الاحتفالات العائلية
أشعر بالطبع من الشركة المصنعة lajouane
هذه الكعكة لأنها تبدو وكأنها
ينقل شيئًا معينًا
قيمة لجميع الشباب وللجميع
الناس الذين يأتون لزيارتنا
[موسيقى]
أو